well Damien green was effectively Deputy
Prime Minister under Theresa May he's
pledged his support to Penny Morden he
joins us now thank you so much for being
on the program good morning so why Penny
Morton well because I think she's the
best candidate to unify the party and
looking at the country in the end is
what matters in this what we desperately
need is a period of calm competent
stable government and to do that you
need a United party and Penny is a
candidate who is attracting support from
all wings of the party you've just done
an interview with Steve and he was
talking a lot about eurosceptics and
brexities and Penny of course was a very
strong supporter of brexit I supported
remain so you know this is a visible
sign that penny is the best place to all
the candidates actually to bring a very
fractious party together and and that
but that's worth it in itself but
actually what I care most about is the
country and unless we have that kind of
stable Unified Government then we're not
going to be able to stabilize the
country we've got a difficult period
ahead and I think that calm stability is
what the next government should aim that
and Penny would provide that um you say
she's attracting support from all wings
of the party I guess the problem is is
it enough support you know because you
know has she got the numbers how many
MPS is your now I mean well they're a a
lot a lot more than 23 because a lot of
a lot of colleagues are are not saying
for various reasons I wouldn't criticize
them for that
um but it's it's multiples of 23. I
think where would you we're confident of
I I won't reveal numbers partly because
they you know they change by the hour
they grow by the hour
um but I'm confident that the penny will
get uh over the line tomorrow do you
think she'll get over 100 yes okay um so
no question of her pulling out today
then rowing in behind another candidate
she's in it to win no no she she is in
it to win okay um you um I just wonder
that you know you're talking about unity
and the important of you know of what
the country needs stability Unity with
that in mind is it not in the National
interest for Penny to show that unity
and row in behind another candidate if
it is going to be difficult for her you
know potentially to go on and win this
contest I don't think so because the
other uh a I think she'll win uh but B
uh you know we have a process and if
it's all stitched up Behind Closed Doors
by
big figures at Westminster then our
party members will feel cheated um we
you know we do have this two-stage
process and I think it I think it's a
sensible Innovation that we have this
indicative vote so we will know as MPS
who's ahead but if the party members
might feel a little bit bruised anyway
because you've effectively told them
that they got it wrong last time well we
I mean we haven't told them that I mean
it did it did go wrong you know Liz
admitted mistakes it was it's been a a
terrible few weeks
um and and she stood down but um I think
what in this uh context what we do need
is is to respect the process and if it's
an Evidence stitch up as I say I think
our party membership uh will be pretty
disgruntled about that and that would be
a bad way for a new prime minister to to
set out on the journey you are talking
about the the Optics of the stitch up
and how people would react to that you
know there are obviously reports of
Boris Johnson and Richie soon like
having talks and last night do you think
that that kind of potential deal making
could be seen as a Stitcher well I don't
know and I think none of us knows what
happened at those talks or what was
discussed or indeed whether they've
stitched anything up we you know we
don't know but I think the fact that we
we are talking about it in those terms
suggests the danger of that that if they
turn around and say right you know the
two of us have decided what's going to
happen to the country then uh you know
perhaps you know many of my colleagues
and certainly the party members and
possibly the country as well will think
hang on that's not the way this is
supposed to work what do you think of
the idea of a Boris Johnson prime
minister round two well I think we we
saw what happened last time and how the
government sort of literally fell apart
uh with you know 60 odd uh resignation
so uh I I you know I just don't think it
would work and I think particularly not
at this time I think we all know that
there's this standards committee uh
investigation going on and as long as
that's going on
um there is the possibility of if if he
became leader again then in a couple of
months time we'd all be here again and
absolutely we should not put the country
through that
now it's the second time of course that
Penny Morden ran for the leadership she
I think came third last time and fell
short backless trash this is what she
said about Liz truss at hustings in
August who can lead who can deliver who
does have that bold economic plan and
Nation needs I've seen enough to know
who that person is and that is Liz Truss
if Penny Morden genuinely believed that
Liz trust had the Bold economic plan our
nation needs what does that say about
her judgment well I think I mean a
majority of people supported Liz I I
didn't I voted for Rishi in in that
phase having supported penny in the
previous couple of rounds
um and you know we had a decision
between two candidates
um and you know Liz herself admits that
you know she had an economic plan but
tried to do it too far too fast with the
terrible consequences we saw uh in the
markets because as you say but you know
penny more than sat in the cabinet and
she signed off on measures of the budget
well I think I think one of the things
we do know is that the cabinet weren't
consulted about about that budget that
it was it was agreed between Liz and
quasi
um and then and then announced basically
so I I don't hold the voice the cabinet
responsible didn't stand up to Liz
Transit shoes she sat in the cabinet she
backed the plants well I mean the the
cabinet I think met literally three
times uh in its whole period so I think
trying to blame members of the cabinet
for what's happened over the past two
months is actually unfair just you know
for various reasons uh they they weren't
meeting you know for obvious reasons
given what else was happening uh in the
world but I think uh where we are now
then we need someone who who does share
the overall vision of a lower tax
smaller state but who recognizes the
reality that the most important thing is
to stabilize the economy uh to make sure
that Britain is a credible player in the
world again and Penny has already taken
steps she said she would leave Jeremy
Hunter's Chancellor I think that's a
very important step forward we've seen
that Jeremy with all his experience has
stabilized the pound stabilized the
guilts market so that is a very strong
message to send to the outside world in
the end although this is an internal
party election it's what happens in the
outside world that's going to decide on
the success of the next prime minister
and the next government and Penny's
already taken a significant step
forwards to that and it's interesting to
talk about Penny's pennymordans planned
because I guess the criticism that some
MPS have is they just don't know that
much about what her vision is about what
she stands for you know I remember the
last leadership election Ian Duncan
Smith telling me he doesn't know what
Paddy Morden has achieved in government
Lord froster when he worked with her she
wasn't always visible sometimes I didn't
even know where she was is she a bit of
a submarine yeah I think I think that
that last criticism is particularly
unfair and I can say that with some
Authority I was Secretary of State for
working pensions when Penny was the
disabilities Minister and I didn't know
her very well when I went went into that
job and I was tremendously impressed
both by the the effort she put in the
work she put in and what's a very
difficult brief
um but also the imagination she showed
she she revived the disability confident
campaign and there are tens of thousands
of people with disabilities in work
today who wouldn't have been had she not
done that so I so she's a very very
effective operator and in terms of the
vision
um she she has if you like and Orthodox
conservative Vision in a patriotic
Vision that says that you know we want
to provide opportunity for people we
want to make sure that the public
finances are sound and we want to make
sure that Britain can pay its way in the
world can act as a big player in the
world and can do that while trying to
keep the state under control spend every
penny of public money effectively so
it's an orthodox conservative Vision but
but that's what the conservative party
stands for it's interesting listening to
what you just said there about new
opportunity about patriotism about
public finances I mean you could imagine
we're actually seeing that saying
exactly the same thing you know what's
the dividing line what's the reason that
people should back penny more than other
than the front runner well I think that
the the I mean the difference is that of
all the candidates uh well and there
aren't very many but but of the three of
them penny is the one who people will
instinctively rally around you know
we're already talking about the
possibility of the other two doing a
deal to try and unify the party Penny
doesn't need to do deals to unify the
party and stabilize the government
because of what she stands for and
because of the work she's done she can
do that herself and that I think makes
her the strongest candidate just very
quickly if she doesn't make it I know
you think she will will you be backing
Rishi neck again uh I will I will see
what happens but I'm not anticipating
that so I haven't thought about it yet
fair enough thank you very much for
being on the program today Damien green